so the three major releases that have
come out this weekend this is the best
reviewed one it's Canada Day a I'm not
Canadian I just like it there
yeah that's not Monte Carlo I'm not a
conformist I do got one this movie stars
Selena Gomez Leaton Meister and Katie
Cassidy is that how you say their names
I'm not sure they're on this big
vacation to Paris and it starts you know
really bad for them they don't like it
there then all of a sudden Selena Gomez
gets mistaken for this rich heiress and
somehow gets shoot in to her suite at
this huge hotel then suddenly starts to
live the life of this heiress in secret
while getting all these little perks and
going to these fancy restaurants and
everyone thinks that she's this heiress
when she's really not now I'm gonna say
something that's gonna really surprise
you just not to deal with it I actually
really like this movie now before you
hit the unsubscribe button please allow
me to tell you something I really like
the rock standing Private Ryan diehard
and Indiana Jones have I affirmed my
manliness yet as somebody said something
about it it was really cute and charming
and there's obviously a reason it's the
best reviewed film this weekend I
thought the main three girls worked
really well together I really liked the
photography of Paris and I just felt
that the whole story was actually kind
of involving I can tell he that I found
myself liking this movie because I went
into it thinking I'm just gonna go do
this and I really don't care I remember
about 20 minutes to a half an hour in
the movie I just had this revelation I
was sitting there and I just kind of
this movie really isn't that bad I'm not
a conformist I'm not gonna be like oh I
don't want to see this movie just
because it has some Disney Channel
people or something now there are some
problems with it don't get me wrong it
falls into those cliches where people
who are suddenly liking each other so
they keep running into each other all
the time you're in a giant city of Paris
how does this guy keep running into this
girl how do these people keep running
into each other it's it's not possible
because the script wants them to it
works this film has a lot of cheesy
parts like where you're supposed to feel
romantic when it's really kind of sappy
but the thing is the main story of this
film I found myself involved in the
story if you're the kind of guy who
doesn't mind watching a movie that's
clearly aimed towards females if you
have any part of you that is in some way
shape or form sensitive then you might
find certain aspects of this film
entertaining this is a very honest
review and I'm going to tell you that
Monte Carlo gets three out of four stars
for me but leave my female demographic
is about 20% so more than likely this
isn't exactly your cup of tea but I like
movies so I'm going to recommend this
movie it's really not that bad it's a
charming little movie it has a lot of
cheesy sappy little moments but it's it
does what it does well and I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna lie I enjoyed it